an American the circus was familiar but
the circumstance unique the former
president speaking for the first time as
a criminal defendant walking to the
stage like a boxer to the ring and this
was classic Donald Trump counter
punching lights on the facts and heavy
on the attacks I never thought anything
like this
could happen in America never thought it
could happen
the only crime that I have committed is
to fearlessly defend our nation from
those who seek to destroy it this fake
case was brought only to interfere with
the upcoming 2024 election
and it should be dropped immediately
possible to get inside Donald Trump's
head to know what he's really thinking
beneath the bravado but somewhere Behind
These Walls at Mar-A-Lago he is still
digesting the full detail of the case
against him his allies in the Tabloid
media have come out to back him they
think these are trumped-up charges too
polling shows those who supported him
before still do would this indictment
affect whether you vote for him or not
no no not at all no it just seems like a
ploy by the Democratic party trying to
make sure that he's not able to run side
by side in restaurants and bars across
America people with wildly different
views I was in high school when George W
Bush was elected and I remember thinking
like oh this is terrible like we don't
want someone who's conservative in
office like I disagree with this man and
I am now longing for the days of a Bush
Junior Senior reagan-esque country
but in the Sunshine State there is the
possibility that Donald Trump could be
eclipsed by a rival close to home
Rhonda santis Florida's governor a man
with trumpian politics is also likely to
run to be the Republican nominee in
2024. oh I absolutely would vote for
Iran but I think it would do us all or
would do the Republican Party Justice if
Donald Trump would just step back and
promote a new candidate
[Applause]
Trump though Remains the most likely
Challenger for the White House despite
the possibility that he may be on trial
when campaigning begins it would be
another breathtaking chapter in a
political career which continues to
divide this country Martha Kellner Sky
News Florida